we're in the endgame now [ __ ]
whoa the Chris Evans just walk through
the door whoa one knackered looking
penis mass Greg I'll let John know
you're here then we could get going okay
buddy well Greg you do know I only have
one extra ticket right I can't bring
John I can't tell them that oh hey John
that's a inaccurate looking good more
outfit thanks Kyle
that looks terrible yeah Alex well can't
you guys tell me
hey man I'm really sorry I only got one
guest pass for Greg you know how these
press screenings are well Greg and I
promised each other the first time we
watched this it would be together so if
I can't go
he can't either right Greg Greg you're
not gonna go without me are you no I
ignored an MCU screening once I cannot
do that again even for you I won't let
you go without me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] dude I got an extra ticket to the
endgame screening is this an old message
this girl canceled on me she pulled the
whole meet to card it got very awkward
can you buzz me in this is great this
means I can go down
[Music]
no wait Greg thank you think about this
that no hi guys I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey I'm Kaila ermine Carlin from
fan theory TV thanks for being here
buddy
thank you to everyone who helped us out
with that little opening sketch Patrick
Hogue go follow him on Twitter my
girlfriend Olivia really helped out a
hell of a lot as well the VFX for that
part where they Andrew back from the
dead yeah that was a really fun sketch
to put together hope you guys enjoyed it
we literally have just come home from
watching eventual team we're gonna do
our absolute best to make sure we don't
spoil Jack about this movie expect a
spoiler review from us later on this
week the most I can really do I think
any of us can really do is just sort of
express our feelings on the movie
because the way the Russo brothers
worked with the marketing team or Kevin
Feige whoever like I know a lot of
people really involved with the
marketing for this they did such a great
job at concealing so much that goes on
it's like such a great job and in less
obvious ways perhaps than infinity war -
yeah I made even the trailer
manipulation was different this time I
am so grateful for the trailer
manipulate weird experience be like I am
so glad they hit that [ __ ] in that shot
so much throughout this movie definitely
like the way the trailers pitches is
more of a of a darker piece something I
probably more character-driven as well
because infinity war has so many
different characters and this is not
infinity War part two this is like a
completely different kind of movie and
tone style the story they're telling
even the scope and how they're capturing
this specific tale and I felt it was
more character-driven
it's definitely a much more heavy on the
drama and you know what [ __ ] I'm
gonna say it with infinity war I
remember watching that feeling like I
have to process this a little bit before
I really realize how I feel about this
movie I don't know where it ranks terms
of all the MCU I would definitely say
this is probably most likely my favorite
Avengers movie in terms and that's
including Captain America Civil War
which is like essentially an Avengers
film 25 minutes into this movie I
remember thinking man this is great
so different this is so unexpected and
in the surprises wouldn't stop and the
drama kept delivering the actions great
- I loved love this honor and it's not
one of those things like he's having
euphoric high because he just came out
of it no I know how I feel about this
movie I agree with everything you said
it was definitely full of surprises to
say the least definitely was a
culmination of everything we've been
working towards and I mean that in every
sense of that word I didn't see a lot
coming and normally I see these things
coming it's normally what I do
I was definitely definitely surprised
there's a lot there's a lot load there's
so much in this movie that I can't
really say without spoiling it felt
totally like unique and it totally was
Marvel Studios movie yeah it really is
and you know from me coming out of
infinity war like there's the like you
said there's a whole lot to take in and
process and for me I feel like I'm still
absorbing the impact of this movie but
in that same breath I will say like
whatever expectations I set forth for it
I think it definitely satisfied those I
mean it surprised me with a good amount
of things and it also just gave me a
good amount of things that I was hoping
for or was expecting you know we've all
got predictions and theories and whatnot
but the kinds of beats I was hoping they
would deliver for the most part they do
moments here or there where you could
tighten things up it's a three hour
movie but for the most part it flew by
for me and I was always pulled in and
that's something because I think on this
panel of three these movies are more
favorites for you guys and I really
admire what the Russo brothers have been
able to do with these because both
infinity war and this feel like really
distinct events and yeah like especially
pitted against some of the previous
Avengers movies I mean I always hold the
first one as special because it achieves
something special and I feel like
infinity war and this movie and game
have done that again for the first time
since in terms of like the culmination
aspect I think all of us off that's what
infinity wars gonna be you know and in a
way it is in a way it is but this one
especially that's the defining
culmination of the MCU you truly truly
yeah it's like infinity war is a
culmination of perhaps all the
characters and plot lines colliding but
I feel like endgame is the culmination
of the spirits the character development
in here
does it have that Marvel humor yeah it
does there's oh yeah there's really
really funny moments but the drama like
more than any Avengers movie it really
hit hard the one thing I would say to
expect a little bit is there will be
some slower moments I don't I don't
think they're dull moments I don't think
there's any boring moments there are
moments really like oh they're really
letting the drama play out here they're
really letting these characters just
interact here I'd love that they did
that especially for an Avengers Assemble
kind of movie it's so hard to infinity
war is a shorter movie with way more
stuff jammed into it and this movie has
a lot to get done too but that was one
thing I definitely appreciated was also
the shift in tone and the embracing not
that it's somber throughout but yeah
giving some of these moments more life
to breathe so that when the journey
actually kicks off you know it really
does feel as natural as it can be for
how immediate needs to be I felt
infinity were kind of jam-packed with
characters yeah yeah without necessarily
focusing as much on the characters
whereas this movie it was focusing truly
on the story and on the characters and
their connection to each other I mean to
me this is my favorite Clint Barton best
nebula we've gotten definitely I mean if
you already love Captain America and
Tony Stark like all the other ones here
you're gonna just really love them here
there's additions to be had with them
it'd take every character here to
another level they take everything
really elevate everyone here I just love
the mood of this that was one of the
other things that I was kind of taken
aback by I thought like maybe the
trailers are just showing it's just dark
and heavy the mood in some ways there
are scenes here that just feel like a
mood piece it is that like high-stakes
you know like finality like the closing
of a chapter of sorts it stands out way
way apart from all the other movies not
just Avengers but the entire MCU in
terms of its tone and how its unique it
really is an app yeah expect the
unexpected because there are things that
maybe perhaps you've been wanting to see
in an MCU movie that you're gonna get
here there are things that maybe you
predicted might happen but then when
they do it it's even there were tears to
be had I won't say why
there were tears I had [ __ ] early on
his shoes and their tears yeah I won't
say when the tears took place but there
are times in this movie where you do
hear the whole theater crying there's
also a lot of really good comedy that
they they still yeah it in here any
different kind of suspense and different
kind of tension that we're used to in
these MCU films that don't just rely on
heavy-handed spectacle really good
directing and writing you know yeah and
I think to a degree a collision between
a massive blockbuster spectacle with
more film inclinations on his mind and
one thing - I think they did a really
beautiful job and a very natural job of
is tying in the history of the ten
eleven years we've spent building this
world on screen true and I won't go into
grave detail about that but I thought
you know especially with the way they
rolled out the ads being like look how
far we've come
I thought the movie was absolute it yet
in a nice way this is the ultimate
fanservice movie for the MCU but it
doesn't just solely rely on that it uses
that those elements to truly tell a tale
and even make stories that you might not
really it does retro actively use some
things in it yeah we'll see anymore or I
won't say anymore but yeah I love this
one I don't know where ranks the MCU for
me personally but I think in terms of
the Avengers movie it's got to be my
favorite absolutely mad significance man
all right guys well I don't know leave
your thoughts nation click that
notification bell the lucky person is
gonna get a shout out here from her
patreon page today is a woman named
Jenna Randolph hey Jenna is someone who
attends a lot of cons in her state of
Wisconsin where she lives out at if she
doesn't get to travel as much as she
likes you with Jenna
I've gotten to really know you over the
past couple months you are such a
sweetheart I just want to thank you so I
know I usually make some kind of weird
sarcastic joke I just want to thank you
so much for being here you are truly a
delight and just lucky and I know how
much you love getting these shout outs
but really like the the amount
of positive energy of thrown our way
does not compare it all to like whatever
the hell we say in a funny shoutouts I
just want to say something sincere and
lastly follow Kyle van theory TV see you
guys go watch endgame